well along similar lines I was curious I
as you have expanded new menta and palm
I it was curious why you had chosen to
why you have chosen to donate to Yale a
huge organization that receives many
monetary donations every year huge
monetary donations and as here's you
know as a class our selves as a seminar
that has a hundred thousand dollars to
work with what do you advise for us you
chose to donate to a large organization
like Yale versus a smaller organization
and you know searching and looking into
various organizations ourselves we're
wondering why whether we should choose
the against malaria foundation that
serves many many people that have
suffered from malaria in in African
countries that support you know they
give a give net send that go over the
beds and it saves many lives or should
we look towards more to locally to the
Columbus house that you know provides a
safe haven for people suffering from
homelessness right in our area and i was
wondering kind of what you suggest for
us and and where we should look and what
you know that's a that's a great
question their first of all I will tell
you this there's no bad cause so if
you're looking for the ones to come in
we could say you know what that's a bad
cause we're not confessing it does
doesn't exist all the causes are good
and you could sit here for the next 24
hours and tell me great causes so one
does need to choose and my husband and I
kind of confronted this issue a few
years ago and said because we were just
kind of randomly just picking things
that sounded interesting and you know
not really thinking about it and we
decided we had to think about this and
be more deliberate about it and so we
actually came up with a system and this
is what our system looks like I think
you have to think about your own system
but i'll share our system with you we
came up with a matrix and we said across
the top are things that are important to
us so the arts education addressing
poverty were Jewish so Jewish issues
whatever we had you know the things
across the top and then down the side we
had kind of regional local regional
national international and then we took
everything we were giving all the
dollars and we plotted them in this to
just say well what are we doing let's
start out with a question of where are
we giving money and understand it and
and that process get really opened my
eyes to a few things because I realized
there were some things that we weren't
doing that we should be doing some
things that we were maybe overdoing that
we didn't need to be doing so we've used
that as a framework for ourselves to
figure out which things we we want to do
and we then contest things on that so
when something comes in that's in one of
those areas then we look and see are we
already invested enough in that area or
not okay is this something we should
consider and it gives us it gives us a
framework then we look at other criteria
like I think your question is a really
good one of you know why give money to
Yale when they have so much money
because after all you know it's just a
drop in the bucket I'm not a billionaire
I'm not going to go you know give a
hundred million dollars to build the
next building here I simply can't make
that kind of an impact at Yale so my
impact is going to be far less I gave
money to the last campaign and they I
dedicated it to the new bass library
just because that was such a big deal
for me having spent CCL my hopefully
undergraduate career and so but it was
you know it was enough to just get my
plaque on the wall so everybody calls it
Donna's wall so you can go visit my
plaque on the wall at CCL wasn't a
building so I'm not going to make an
impact at Yale like other people can but
the the you know still I feel it's
important to participate so I choose to
participate at Yale I know as a member
of the corporation that a huge
percentage of the cost of educating a
student here is not paid by tuition even
somebody paying full tuition so one
needs to get that the rest of that from
donations are from the endowment and so
I feel I attended here on somebody
else's money to a great extent and so I
need to provide that for you guys and
the next generation so I feel sometimes
I'm giving for participation purposes
because I feel like it's an institution
that was important to me that I want to
participate other times I'm giving where
I really feel like our money and the
scale we can give will make a difference
where where we can have a direct impact
on what's going to happen and without us
it wouldn't happen and so those are we
have a mix of those things i would say